[Music]
and don't donate news Wow all submitted
by just yeah a homeless woman's tweets
why you shouldn't donate to the
Salvation Army goes I would let her how
is a homeless woman
I never donate to the Salvation Army I
just give them [ __ ]
I want to hear pertain uh I'm with part
homeless woman yeah how she's tweeting
from an iPhone
well homeless ranged too though that's
the level of homeless oh that's right oh
really yep so a homeless lady going into
the after source temporarily homeless
and jested we are someone that was
temporarily homeless for like a year
yeah but he wasn't tweeting she was
trying to find foods to eat Heather snow
she is from is she related to drawn
small
would you like the reader said I I would
love to read it oh no
hey [ __ ] you would be x-rays is David
but not all homeless people sound like
that there's some that sound like hey
hey and the homeless person is staying
at a Salvation Army shelter
please don't donate to the Salvation
Army it has like almost 30,000 with
shelter though which one oh she's a
thing in general so still experience
don't donate their money don't donate
your time don't donate your toiletries
blankets or food do not support this
organization the shelter I'm staying at
is one specifically meant for housing
vulnerable women but there's precious
little help here
there's no aid or comfort the RAS are
cruel and robotic and often treat us
like we're less than human I often hear
me speak natively under women here we're
looked down on condescended to and when
one of us attempts to stand up for our
dignity were thrown out onto the street
with a smile in the absolute most
singsong tone bye you can come back in
30 days I seem to Messick violence
survivors thrown out into the dark
wailing and screaming and sobbing
because they dared to get a little
mouthy they literally put up signs
threatening women here with prosecution
if they took too much toilet paper they
frequently throw women with mental
illnesses out of here if they have any
sort of symptoms especially verbal tics
but the really insidious part is that
after they throw these women out if they
don't pick up their stuff within seven
days it's confiscated confiscated and
sold alongside all your donations at
their [ __ ] third stores the women in
here we don't get any of that Shou
women's valuables and their belongings
frequently go missing while in the staff
possession and there's no recourse
available just external the shoulders
and a well I don't know and if you show
any anger or indignation over it you're
out here's the loss on the fridge for
those who don't
I've said here okay so no on the fridge
with locks why is there locks you don't
have access to the food until it's time
that they say or something like that
here's the shower mold this bucket here
the shower wall oh she's just showing
proof
of the living conditions and then she
continues that's another thing as a
trans woman if I step out of line my
punishment will be much more severe
trans women are generally excluded
banned for at least twice as long as CIS
women since women are for the same
infractions what does this woman like a
woman that was born a woman and you
identify yourself as a woman so like if
you're male you identify yourself as a
male than yourself all that [ __ ] is so
convenient so computing about all this
stuff so it's like as we progressed it's
all about human equality right we're all
humans we're all well know colors
whatever but then why are we coming up
with more and more terms to categorize
ourselves we're just separated let's
just all be humans I am a human identify
the human don't matter if I have a dick
or if I want to play with dicks or suck
a dick but suck a vagina who cares I'm a
Hume and I think we as people just like
labels I think that's really what it is
I'm just an explorer
that's why don't be doubt donating
Salvation Army that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Santa Claus every [ __ ] Christmas Eve
out there Bing Bing Bing Bing we took a
[ __ ] man I'm trying to get some
lettuce [ __ ] what the plug there's like
it's right I'm going to read like other
people commenting on the original tree
we just read so this person at Salvation
Army us what do you say about this and
the Salvation Army responded on Twitter
hey Lisa we've been in touch with her
and are addressing it this doesn't
portray our values and we're working to
fix it a different person says I guess
the good old copy and paste text to seem
like there's a real person behind the
screen clap clap s a real nice and then
they respond to that person saying there
actually is a real person here but it's
hard to come up with a new thing to say
each time there's only so much to say
this early on and a different person
says my brother had similar horror
stories from his time and an essay rehab
I reached out to them and was just told
god bless you and nothing more so the
Salvation Army respond to that to that
person saying hey can at risk of
sounding repetitious DM us some contact
info and we'll address sorry to hear you
had a bad experience so then just
they've been responding to a lot of
people responding to this thread and so
what's been reported is that they did
meet with Heather
they had like a successful meeting so
they say and that they they did agree
with a lot of what she was saying like
in terms of the mold the bathrooms of
poor ventilation they're saying that
that's all 100% accurate and that there
they're going to be looking into having
better conditions living conditions for
these people on shelters
you know what substance this may very
well be true but I think in this day and
age as long as it comes from one
person's testimony and it goes viral
that's the truth now you know like this
lady could have taken stock images put
it up make up a story like the stuff
that we see with the airlines because we
see the video we see that before during
and after it's like we have enough
information for everyone to kind of like
conjure up what they think the truth is
and ask [ __ ] up you can't be dragon
doctor doll like that right but a lot of
these viral stories it's just one person
comes out and it takes down the entire
company and I'm not saying that there
are liars or whatever but it just sucks
that in this day and age all it takes is
one side for people to make up their own
decision and then now we could possibly
be taken down a very proper very
compassionate and philanthropic company
because of just one person's complaint
and that happens all across the board it
could be a restaurant it just takes that
one person to go viral in that whole
entire restaurant goes down true but
sometimes there's companies that fly
people like Delta continually [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] [ __ ] ass [ __ ] who
still haven't messaged me you
[ __ ] I'm going to keep on
tweeting you and messing you every day
until you again I'm sorry or something I
don't want pre [ __ ] or sponsor us yeah -
I just want to I'm sorry you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] faces but seeing how the
pattern goes they're probably just going
to sponsor one for one something really
cool probably but it always kind of
sucks you guys are dicks for attention
and just did all our friends look at who
passes up on a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] your [ __ ] what do you pay your
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude the whole service
that makes no sense at all that's not
trying to do all lips no teeth come on
now never going back on what you're
saying just now about the fact that the
must be a really good
company and is being all brought down by
so much they're all there were a lot of
people responding to this thread saying
like I stayed there it was wonderful the
staff was wonderful I was clean so I
didn't have ice but it also depends on
the location later than 100 locations
yeah you know we've been to a really
good McDonald's before we've been to
some like what the [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
every order McDonald's you know yeah so
it all depends like I feel like the
staff they're all different people
running whatever experience are always
going to be different but the cool thing
is now there's accountability with you
know stuff like Twitter and stuff like
Instagram or whatever you take a picture
of something messy and you can you know
[ __ ] expose it and they'll get on it
immediately versus in the past if like a
doctor dollars incident happen or
whatever it only varies within that you
know that small group or even a homeless
woman having a voice like most of the
time no one's listening no one cares
did you guys enjoyed that episode of
just continues if you did please leave a
comment down below and share us your
thoughts and your feelings for more
episodes click right up here
[Music]